[Musik]
kritisch
genf globale enklave der diplomatie
internationale lunge der
finanzwirtschaft genf hat sich schon
immer anders gefühlt als der rest der
schweiz beim stammbaum seiner gäste hat
genf nie allzu genau hingeschaut
es hat daraus vielmehr ein argument für
seinen tourismus gemacht wie im april
seit einem monat lebt der 23-jährige
adwords nudel hier unter demselben
pseudonym dass er schon mit 17 jahren
hatte dokumentiert als snowden sein
leben in genf im chat in seinen
nachrichten spielt er den kneipen kumpel
in wirklichkeit arbeitete amerikaner
unter diplomatische tarnung für die cia
[Musik]
diese wahl ist vorne also insofern
problematisch diplomatie protection
diplomatique das hat auch per mail
[Musik]
vorab haben
16 sie bietet ihm die auslandsvertretung
eine große wohnung mit blick auf die
runde
die auslandsvertretung bringt ihr
personal in den obersten etagen unter
abgeschottet von neugierigen blicken
attachés zur wirtschaftsförderung oder
kooperations beauftragte eine simple
tarnung wie sie auch snowden bei der uno
genießt um weniger rühmliche tätigkeiten
zu vertuschen
bei aller volksschulen und wahre trouvé
die gravitation genie das internationale
genf ist eine gewaltige spielwiese für
den jung snowden das viertel von den
seeufern bis zum flughafen beherbergt
ungefähr 20 internationale
organisationen genf zählt zudem 236
diplomatische auslandsvertretung von
sehr klein zu immens großen
[Musik]
balkon nachtruhe und das von der region
ab die das ist gut
die ermittlungsmethoden realen die
diskussion altären die delegation chinas
[Musik]
jeden morgen passiert snowden die
dreifache sicherheitskontrolle kommt an
den überwachungskameras des hofer zu
amerikanischen auslandsvertretungen
vorbei das riesige gebäude nur einige
meter vom palais de nation und dem ikk
entfernt der amerikaner arbeitet in den
obersten etagen
dort regieren die starken arme des
amerikanischen geheimdienstes die nsa
und cia und bilden eine spezialeinheit
aus den special collection service deren
aufgabe lautet und dann größtmöglicher
geheimhaltung jede kommunikation
abfangen die auf sechs genannte einheit
betreibt in genf eine seiner weltweit 80
stationen
[Musik]
ach was
doch nicht nicht sicher für den
journalisten dann kann campbell der seit
mehr als zehn jahren die aktivitäten des
scs untersucht ist gerade die geheime
quelle des amerikanischen geheimdienstes
[Musik]
sieht man die fassaden der
amerikanischen vertretung setzt diese
mit ihren solaranlagen er auf
energieeffizienz als auf spionage keine
antennen nichts da die großen ohren sind
in wirklichkeit winzig sehen sie das
dann ja genau dort im betonklotz hinter
den plastikstreifen aus fingierten beton
verbirgt sich ein gewaltiges abhör
system aber warum gerade dort die
auslandsvertretung ist ein stück amerika
in genf nach dem wiener übereinkommen
über diplomatische beziehungen sind
botschaften und auslandsvertretung
unantastbares hoheitsgebiet die schweiz
kann nicht einfach klingeln und sagen
hey leute ihr verletzt hier unsere
landrechte man muss sich gar nicht
ausmalen
die realität ist viel aufregender
[Musik]
laut dem snowden dokumenten spioniert an
küsten von genf aus folgendermaßen wie
die post verfügt washington über
verschiedene orte der datensammlung genf
ist ein großer davon
die in genf abgefangene kommunikation
wandert nach england und deutschland
genauer gesagt nach wiesbaden wo
praktisch die gesamte abgefangene
kommunikation europas ankommt nämlich im
sogenannten forschungszentrum der nsa
diese informationen werden in standard
daten umgewandelt überqueren den
atlantik und kommen in eine sortier
stelle der nsa in maryland codenamen
seit sie diese sortier stelle leitet die
datenpakete weiter zum sitz der nsa in
fort mide
an dem die analysten sie lesen und in
berichten festhalten
jegliche kommunikation auch die der
schweiz
doch
[Musik]
zumal washington nicht allein ist in der
nähe vom flughafen befindet sich die
britische auslandsvertretung die über
denselben spitzelapparat verfügt ebenso
wie die chinesen und die russische
auslandsvertretung im september 2018
taucht die stadt calvins in der
delikaten streep affäre auf die die
beziehung zwischen london und moskau
schwer belasten das klima ist ein
ehemaliger doppelagent der in england
lebt und sechs monate zuvor mit seiner
tochter einen giftanschlag überlebt hat
nach der untersuchung durch scotland
yard hatten sich die beiden verdächtigen
zwei russen den monat zuvor in genf
ausgehalten
das heißt sie hätten sich an spionage
aktivitäten in der schweiz beteiligt
eine vertrauliche auswertung aus bern
die in le matin dimanche und der
sonntagszeitung veröffentlicht wurde
betont dass einer von vier russischen
diplomaten in genf ein agent sein genie
dollar gewann war jedoch zwischen 1992
und 96 hat einen geheimagenten für den
französischen geheimdienst eingesetzt
der modus operandi ist nicht sehr
kompliziert
wie beurteilt die neutrale und
unabhängige schweiz amerikanische
spionage auf ihrem territorium
die schweiz tut was sie am besten kann
steigen um nicht das gesicht zu
verlieren
2013 spielte ueli maurer diese partitur
virtuos als er sich mit zahlreichen
journalisten fragen zu den snowden
enthüllungen konfrontiert sah weder
bestätigt noch bricht tritt der
ehemalige vorsteher des vbs die
aktivitäten der amerikanischen
überwachung in der schweiz berlin sprach
gar von hysterie die anfragen der
parlamentarier carlo sommaruga und
balthasar glättli blieben ebenso
erfolglos was der bundesrat öffentlich
nicht preisgeben will werden war schon
immer von den amerikanern abhängig
[Musik]
fakt ist die schweiz tut sehr viel mehr
als nur geben
sie kooperiert heimlich mit washington
diese geheim verbindung tauchen in den
noten dokumenten
diskretion
die problematik die schweiz muss also
ein doppelleben führen
doch snowden und andere haben diese
doppelbödigkeit publik gemacht es ist
also zeit dass bernd sein coming-out
wagt
[Musik]
die schüsse wohl kaum die schweiz hat
seinen wohlstand auf der kunst der
diskussion gebaut das geheimnis ist viel
zu kostbar um es preiszugeben
[Musik]